and that's great denial by doncic  leonard mid-range so lethal  kawhi leonard nails it good offense  though the last two possessions they've  got good looks at the three  leonard cross over twice pull up jumper  puts it in  kawhine leonard now gives the clippers a  three-point lead he's got 37.  leonard pull-up jumper it's good kawhi  leonard with 39 as we get under three  minutes remaining on my way  exactly what he wants  [Applause]  and he wants this matchup five to shoot  leonard step back three bang  body out of my way allow me to have this  dance knock down the shot  put his team on his back there's the  double  katum back to leonard shot clock at six  leonard step back three pucks it in he  does it again  the lead is eight with 140 remaining big  play after big play  all night long doesn't matter who's  defending him  he's in the zone right now and his  mentality is  make a play and he has not disappointed